Speaker 1: The former president of the United
States, Donald Trump, was arrested and perp
walked yesterday in New York City police custody
with no handcuffs and reportedly no mugshot
and pleaded guilty. Sorry, pleaded not guilty.
What a Freudian slip. Pleaded not guilty to
34 different felonies. We will talk about
the alleged crimes. We will talk about the
potential penalties. We will go to the attorney.
Post arrest press conference. Trump's Mar
a Lago speech. We're going to cover everything.
But it's important to sit back for a moment
and understand. It was almost surreal yesterday,
as we did many, many, many, many, many hours
of live streams covering all of this. The
former president arrested and it may only
be the first of many arrests. Reports starting
to swirl about a possible second arrest in
Georgia later this month. We still have questions
about the federal case, but let's not get
to that yet. Donald Trump on his way to the
courthouse posting untruth, social.
Speaker 3: Censure.
Speaker 1: Quote, heading to lower Manhattan.
The courthouse seems so surreal. Wow, They
are going to arrest me. Can't believe this
is happening in america. Maga. And listen,
I agree. It was surreal to so many of us who
were watching. Nearly half a million of you
stopped by the live stream where we covered
Trump's path down to the courthouse in Lower
Manhattan and eventual booking in the entire
thing. It truly was surreal. We have video
here of Donald Trump's motorcade arriving
at the courthouse. Trump getting out and sort
of a lumbering, waiving at one point to the
dozens of supporters that showed up and then
lumbering, surrounded by Secret Service into
the courthouse. There was this very unusual
situation where there was a ring of Secret
Service around Trump and also NYPD and, of
course, New York courthouse court officers
kind of managing the situation as they as
they often do. We then were able to see video
from the 15th floor of Donald Trump entering
the actual courtroom, maybe the first time
in decades that Donald Trump actually had
to hold the door for himself. And here you
see all of these different rings of security.
Let's take a look at this video. There is
Trump entering, looking dejected, quite frankly,
rather close. And very briefly there, as you
see going into the courtroom, these were very,
very brief moments. Trump then spending about
an hour in the arraignment, which is very
unusual. Legal experts weighing in that these
arraignments, even when there are 34 counts
like this, usually there is a a waiving of
the full reading of all of these counts. This
took nearly an hour, and that is not typical
for such an arraignment. And we still don't
know exactly what took so long. We do know
that the judge did admonish everyone that
he wants he I'm sort of paraphrasing here,
but that the judge would like there not to
be public commentary that turns up the heat
on this entire thing that didn't last very
long, that I can assure you. And then about
an hour later video. So let's see. The video
going in was 2:28 p.m.. The video coming out
was 3:24 p.m. So almost a full hour to the
minute. Here is Donald Trump leaving the courtroom
And again, a very, very brief sighting of
trump.
Speaker 2: They're about to come out of the
court room. Let's listen in to the hall.
Unidentified: The text question how did you
tweet president trump? How did you blame president
Trump? So we can go ahead.
Speaker 1: And then there goes Trump. And
you see his lawyer, Joe Tacopina, who previously
said Trump did commit a crime when he was
interviewed about this on TV years ago. Okay.
So the judge warning everybody refrain from
statements and social media posts that could
foment unrest. And all of this after there
were many messages critical of the prosecutor
before, though, certainly didn't stop after.
And we are going to get to that. So an incredible
moment. I mean, this really is a historic
moment. It is unusual. It is unique. It is
different. And then now the focus starts to
become what is actually going to happen with
these cases. What are we actually going to
see happen? What are the charges and what
is the maximum possible sentence? Let's talk
about
that next.